usted considera que se debería votar no
en el referendo por qué
yo bueno ante todo Buenas tardes para
toda la audiencia yo creo que realmente
el la negativa a la aprobación de este
código viene dado porque es un código
que en su gran mayoría aunque aunque
incorpora un grupo de derechos que son
universales y que deben ser reconocidos
hay otro grupo de derechos que los
cercena de manera muy amplia sobre todo
en cuanto a todos los relativos a la
responsabilidad parental y las causales
para la privación de que están marcadas
por una falta de definición muy amplia
que admite o da la posibilidad de que
las autoridades de manera discrecional y
a modo de castigo puedan privar a los
padres de esta responsabilidad parental
para inhibirlos a
dejar de ejercer derechos humanos
básicos como los que como los que las
existen
pero si triunfará el Sí sería un
acontecimiento histórico al permitir por
ejemplo el matrimonio igualitario Cómo
se llega a este giro teniendo en cuenta
los antecedentes homófobos de La Isla
y yo creo que se llega a punto partido a
la evolución humana propiamente dicha Yo
creo que es un derecho que le asiste a
esta comunidad desde hace mucho tiempo y
que le ha sido negado durante muchos
años que en este caso Yo creo que es una
de las posibilidades o uno de los
Derechos positivos que incorpora este
código pero la legislación tenemos que
analizarla desde mi punto de vista de
una manera integral no solamente porque
se incorpore un grupo de derechos
podemos dar la posibilidad de que se
apruebe una legislación que a priori Se
observa que va a ser extremadamente
perjudicial para el resto de los
ciudadanos incluso para los miembros de
esta comunidad que van a ser
beneficiados con el reconocimiento de
este derecho pero que a su vez se pueden
ver perjudicados a futuro con el
cercenamiento de otros derechos o con la
imposibilidad de ejercer los derechos
que se reconocen de una manera digamos
más amplia y precisamente abordemos esta
cuestión Cómo se aplicaría este código
en el contexto cubano Bueno yo creo que
esa es una pregunta muy interesante
Porque para mí la mayor falencia el
contexto cubano es la posible aplicación
material de las leyes hay un grupo de
aspecto de derechos que se recogen en
esta ley que básicamente eran
obligaciones que ya el gobierno cubano
tenía que cumplir y que a día de hoy las
incumple prácticamente a diario por
ejemplo el interés superior del menor
este nuevo código una de las cosas que
incorpora este interés superior del
menor que ya está recogido en la
Constitución y además de esto en todos
los estándares Internacionales que
integran la legislación cubana pero sin
embargo en la práctica todos los días lo
vemos violentado o sea el gobierno
cubano en modo alguno toma para para sus
decisiones el interés superior del menor
o la expresión o Los criterios que pueda
tener el menor